Unknown: All say Good day to you this day of your dime
How are you? All?
Right.
Thank you.
This transmission has been titled 2020 the eye of the storm.
We would at this time,
like to get a little bit serious with you,
not the star system so much.
But have what would amount perhaps to be
a heart to heart for what's coming up is very important.
In terms of your timing, we have said that your year of 2020 is a pivotal point in what you call your history.
You are shifting through a very particular moment crossing a very particular threshold. And so at this timing, it is important
for certain stages
Of being to be paramount within you, to help you
through this time to help you cross that threshold in a positive
and constructive manner, for what comes after
will be predicated very strongly
on what you do and who you are in 2020.
We will reinforce the ideas we are about to share with you
at the end of this transmission in your holiday of meditation in a very particular way, but for now,
we would like
each and every one of you to know
how important it is for you to truly be yourselves in the coming year.
How important it will be
For you to make decisions that are in alignment
with your best discernment
how important it will be and how important it is for you to remain at the center of the storm.
Because if I may use some of your colloquial language
2020 is going to be nuts.
It's going to be crazy.
And it is of paramount importance that you remain. If you wish to be on a certain train in the eye of the storm, where it's calm, where peace and solitude rain, where even though you may see the storm raging all around you swirling around you Thunder
During and lightning all around you,
it is more important than ever before. And more important than it will be for quite a long time during this crossing during this threshold during this pivotal year, to be at peace within yourself,
to be calm within yourself to be centered within the eye of the storm.
So we would highly encourage each and every one of you to really take stock of who you really are, and what kind of decisions you really choose to make and how they are or are not in alignment with what you truly wish your world to be.
We will give you a suggestion that may assist for more
Most of you are at least to some degree familiar with what we have told you about how our world functions, who we are
in simple terms, what we stand for, and what reality we are encouraging you to align with, so that you can experience eventually, more contact with us and us with you.
It is crucial, critical in this coming year, to set the stage to set the foundation for the years to come after, with a state of being that represents that which is most harmonious
with the vibration we have shared with you that is representative of our reality if you wish
to have a reality to shift to a version of Earth, where we can interact openly and freely with each other.
In beauty, in harmony, in creativity in love,
and to have the ability to look deep within yourselves,
and not allow the idea
of fear based opinion, to supersede your deep seated knowledge of who you actually prefer to be, and what kind of a world you prefer to live in.
So we encourage you, at any time in this coming year when you allow yourself to stay
at peace and become in the eye of the storm,
to think
of what it would be like if you were one of us,
what kind of decisions would you make if you were coming from our world, but living on earth? How would we respond to the things that happen?
And then come up the circumstances and situations and opportunities that will arise in your year of 2020. And to come from that center of balance, and peace and calm, and solitude and assurance and confidence and knowing this, and come from there, in your actions, in your relations, in your understanding of others that you may encounter on your journey,
and to not settle for those things that you think, in your opinion, are the things that would serve when you know in your heart they may not create the vision of the world that you would really prefer to live in a world that contains the ability to interact with us and other beings like us, that contains the ability to expand your senses instead of contract.
them, so that you may receive as a more receptive antenna, higher frequency information.
by remaining in the center in the eye of the storm, you will be far more capable of being receptive to the images and the information and the messages that we are always constantly sending you remember this, remember this, remember this and take it to heart.
We, we
never leave you. It is you that leave us. So choose the vibration, the frequency, the energy, if you wish
to have that kind of a world that represents what you believe we would do.
If we were you, if you were us in all the situations that may arise in the upcoming story
Stay in the center.
And no matter how it may seem to swirl around you, no matter how scary it may seem,
be discerning of the vibration of those with whom you associate
of those that you would align with that in no way, shape or form, represent the world that in your heart of hearts, you truly prefer to experience.
Now, of course, it is always up to you to make the choices that you believe are true for you. And we would never tell you to do otherwise. All we do is encourage you to understand that if you wish to align with a version of earth that we are aligned with in your future, and have the interactions and the freedom to play among the stars with us. That you choose to remain in the eye of the storm. No matter what
rages around you,
and that you look deep within your heart of hearts and make choices that are really true to your core. And not simply obedient
to the fear based beliefs or opinions that sometimes allow you to think
is the path when you know deep within, it is not
be strong, be courageous and be at peace
in the upcoming time and the crossing of the threshold for everything thereafter will take its cue from the seed you plant that year.
We are always magnifying and amplifying the energies through the different vortices of your planet to help balance your world and give you a greater opportunity to slide smoothly across that threshold.
We have been talking about times of transition now from
quite some time on your planet.
And as we already have experienced with you, things are changing rapidly on your world.
And as we have said they will only get crazier in the year to come.
So do not
make the measure of who you are, as a being by what you see swirling around you. Make that measure by who you know you prefer to be. And stay in the center of the eye, where the calmness and the peace in your heart and your mind, your soul, your spirit will allow you to have the resolve to stand firm in what you know to be true.
really true, deep within your soul, deep within your hearts
so that you can let go of those things that are truly not vibrationally compatible with the world you prefer to create.
There will always be another path.
Just because sometimes your choices may seem limited, doesn't mean they actually are, there is always a third alternative, always.
So let yourself be at peace enough to find it, to see it, to walk it together in harmony, and unison, and love.
We will crystallize this idea, again,
in the meditation at the end of this transmission, but for now, we wanted to have this heart to heart with you.
And if you simply want to allow yourself to simplify everything we have just said, so that you can make your choices, your decisions and discernment more easily than once again, I simply remind you and it can be any name and
In this position that is representative of the same kind of energy of the energy of your higher mind, it doesn't have to be specifically us. But if you're confused at any point, if you feel yourself being tugged away from that center at any point,
just ask
what would the SSID people do?
And do that
and you will be fine and back in the center for you know us well enough to know what we would choose
up to you.
With thank you for allowing us to have this heart to heart with you. And in return for that gift. We ask, How may we continue to be of service to you now, in your dialogues and questions, please begin as you so desire.
Oh, and by the way, you can shake off the series
business now and light now
whoo that was scary
though we rarely would say to go in that direction in this case it might actually be appropriate to be just a tiny bit scared and use the fear in a positive way to align you with what you know is true for you.
You know the CO Ed over mushara is le Oba I'm a quick learner.
I came all the way from Tokyo go all right, I came all the way away message.
What a synchronicity. Yes.
So I'm in the eye of the storm. Yes. It's really important to take action. Yes, the actual Mr language of a physical yesterday or z
stay within that center. Yeah.
Yeah, in the center. So I'd like to ask you,
again, what your definition was the executive definition of action. From your point of view, action, physical action. Yeah. Physical activity, literal, physical activity. You said that, like doing it then but attentional is not fully action. It sets up the state. Let me put it to you by a very simple example.
You walked up to the microphone. Yeah, that's an action. instead of staying in your seat and thinking about walking up to the microphone, not meditating about walking up to the microphone. You walked up to the microphone, that's an action, a physical action. It's not that complicated. Okay. Uh huh. So if I organize a meditation
And maybe I will ask the people around me to participate and actually do the meditation, maybe it's going to be a more action. Again, you can begin with that kind of an action, but you must proceed from there. Once you get yourself into the appropriate state. The meditation is not the end, okay? It's the beginning of an action. And if you get into the proper state, it will actually propel you to then move forward and take actions that are expressions, creative expressions of the energy state that the meditation got you into.
So what's an expression a physical expression of some form of interaction and creativity? Yes. Okay. Yes. So, if I'm in that state, the action naturally unfolds. Maybe to to take the form of outward expression of you will feel the urge to take an action
interact, when you are in the proper state you will want to move you will want to interact with others you will want to share something in a physical creative way. Okay, Okay, I got it. Yes. Thank you. You're welcome. And
it seems that I have to ask about the Serpent Mound. Yes Serpent Mound in Ohio. Yeah, right.
Last night you use head to the I said there are codes if you can decode them in the Serpent Mound that will point you in the direction of where one of the master crystal skulls is buried yet all right. So the Yeah, no.
Thank you for confirming that.
I know you know, the skull is so that skull is Sequoia skull.
Sequoia Sequoia Sequoia Scott. Yes, Sequoia. Okay.
So I thought I didn't I didn't I didn't think that the Ohio could be considered to be a North Eastern regional but the Northeast from where you are now.
Yeah, that's right. Thank you. I know that too.
And
I was kind of a trying to decode that cold water in Serpent Mound. Yes. Well, go ahead, play with it. See what you get? Yeah, my good research. Yeah. My guess is that the scowl maybe in the direction of and through normal slamdance. I am not going to give you any more assistance. Go and do your research going play with it. I do the go to set up on the mound this August. Then have fun. Yeah, I did. All right. See what you get. You're right.
There are many astronomical alignment at the Serpent Mound. Yeah, like its face. It's on its head is facing
the sunset, sunset.
Time of summer solstice solstice. Yes, maybe that's maybe the one clue and maybe
also I was very attracted to the fact that one of the start I have to ask though if you have to ask
the direct drakon constantly constellation about Draco constellation Draco
unstrapped mount is an image sampled mounted imitate
direct constellation as a connection. Okay. And the world one of the stars in director constellation is to be no no pulled star, maybe when the Serpent Mound was created, is that right? I'm not giving you any more.
I'm not asking you for clue. Yes, you are.
Okay.
So, bye bye.
About this information. Okay, bye.
Bye. Oh, just That's it. That's it on the Serpent Mound. Have you got something else? Yes, of course. Yes. All right, then change the subject. Okay, then we're gonna ask about the
dragon again. Yes, I want to ask about the archetype all the stories structures on story, urban story of a dragon being slain or killed by our hero. There are many this kind of a story all over the world and from the ancient time, yes. And so this must symbolize or the present something, some maybe some incident that actually took place in ancient times, I guess, in a sense, it does. It is symbolic of certain things that have happened on your planet historically, yes. But the idea now is to resurrect the dragon which represents ancient knowledge and wisdom.
Yeah, okay. Okay. And I like to pick up one specific specific history from Greek mythology. Yes. About Hercules Hercules. Yes.
And I think what you once told me that the hardcoded that what Hercules represents is an actual individual. Who Yes. The idea again of the offspring of the Annunaki. And humans, what you call the demigods? Yes, right.
This an American is not not the original on the Maquis. But
offshoot group upon the Nike, Hercules, the demigods are offspring of honor. naki and human. Okay. Okay, you following that? Yeah. Okay. Okay. All right. I didn't follow that. All right. Okay, about the story of the hug on Hong Kong.
So the one story is that harkless was told to steal some of the golden apples in the gardens on this is a person in the gardens and there was a there was a dragon was guarding that clean for the apple tree. And so under how Cliff killed the dragon, and the dragon, the dragon named Adam was the image of a director that's dragon was brought up into the sky, all right, they're always going to be positive and negative images of every symbol. So in the idea of resurrecting the ancient wisdom and knowledge, that's the positive side, the slaying of the dragon is simply going within to allow yourself to overcome and supersede the limitations imposed within your genetic structure, so that you may be able to access that ancient wisdom and knowledge again, okay, so that golden apples symbolizes the anatomy
Yes, because it ties directly into your ancient story of the fruit of the tree of knowledge of good and evil. Yeah, like in God in the beginning? Yes. So it ties directly symbolically into that idea that you were prevented as a species from having a certain amount of knowledge that would make you equal to the gods, the Anunnaki. But now it is time for those markers that were turned off to be turned on again, the dragon being representative to some degree of a higher level version of your DNA. The dragon represents the third strand. Oh, really? Oh, that's, that's good to hear. On the article, anybody's up to the end of the story, the image of Toronto, Canada was brought up into the sky and said to have we become the Toronto constellation, yes. Therefore, there are things that are connected to that constellation astronomically that can assist you in
Discovering certain truths, certain ancient knowledge at this time of opening on your planet. Mm hmm. Okay. Okay. So thank you. Hi, please. Thank you. Oh, so that's the end of the money Christian. Thank you. Okay. Bye bye bye bye
lovey bushy are under you Good day.
So it's here in February, earlier this year. And one of the things you know, something that you mentioned to me during the one of the questions and answers, I had the opportunity to speak with then. Just wanted to quickly touch base on that as a result of that I've, I'm in the process of going through some life changes that are very exciting at the moment. Congratulate. Thank you. I'm in the middle of quitting my job and moving to the Amazon jungle. All right. How does shamanistic practices? Yeah, very exciting. So thank you very much. Yes, well, you did it.
So thank you very much. Thank you.
One of the things that you quickly talked about near the end of my q&a was that hybrid turian. Yes. I was wondering if you'd be able to elaborate on that a little bit. I in what direction?
Are there any of them that would like to connect with me at this time? And is there anything that you could give me in relation? There may be, but it's not going to happen in this particular moment in the way that you're talking about. They're always available to be connected with and you can do that yourself. Okay. Is there any guidance that you can provide as to how I can connect with them certain signature frequencies? I can? Well, you understand the formula we've given all of you? Yes, yeah. Because what happens when you act on your passion? You raise your frequency, what happens when you raise your frequency, you become a better antenna and a better receiver of higher frequency Information and Communication. Okay. That's why we give you the formula because it contains every answer you need, for all the things that you desire to connect to, that are relevant for you to experience in your life.
We don't leave anything out. It's completely self contained. Just follow the formula and everything that needs to unfold and every appointment you've made. And every agreement you've made in every communication you need to have from whomever will happen in perfect timing. If you simply continue to raise your frequency by following the formula of acting on your passion to the best you can, with no insistence or assumption of the outcome and remaining in a positive state, no matter what happens. That's it. We can't make it any simpler for you. It's that simple. Just follow the formula. Everything that needs to happen, that will fulfill you and serve you will happen in perfect timing.
Beautiful thinking, just keep moving. Okay, now notes as well.
Just with the channeling, that's something I've been working with and be able to connect with certain frequencies and matching that within my own body and also be using DMT to supplement as well as a way of amplifying that connection, which I found to be a powerful permission slip for me. All right. Is there any advice or any guidance a
Can gave me or any alteration I can make that may well again, as we have said, there are teachers, such as the idea of the DMT and other substances that the Earth itself provides as teachers. But at a certain point, you come to realize that what you're learning is to get into that state on your own without the teacher, so that you can graduate and not allow the teacher to become a crutch. That's Yeah, that's what I found, the more I'm able to get into that state in the more the less I need that sort of teacher but then it's teaching me to reach another level is that able to match as well again, pay attention, it will not always necessarily feel the same as it did before. But you have to know you're in the proper state. And as we have reminded many of you The trick to this is to remember the physics of it. The physics being you cannot experience what you're not the vibration of first. So to even remember, what it was like to have been in that state means you're in the state
Because if you're not in the state, you wouldn't be able to remember what it was like to be in the state. So as soon as you remember, oh, yes, I remember what it felt like to be in that state, you're in the state, you have to be in the state to have the memory.
Make sense? That's the trick. So realize that, and you will simply be in the state automatically anytime you remember what it was like to be in the state.
Awesome. Yes. Yep. Does that help? It does indeed. And so when I'm having my own DMT ceremonies, I'm connecting with certain frequencies and beings and this be mentioned of justice machine elves in certain types of cycles, interesting labels for certain kinds of levels of consciousness that you may encounter, because the DMT has a very specific frequency levels, each of which represents a different domain, a different realm and a different ability and a different level to communicate with different levels of consciousness. Very specific layers.
Within the DMT frequencies will connect you to very specific domains with very specific inhabitants.
Okay, is there any way that I can more consciously choose to match certain frequencies that will then allow me to assist me in? Actually sorry, squash that question.
Let me see.
There is this thing I've heard about called following your passion.
Maybe that might help. Definitely. It just came into my thought at the moment, one of the things I do want to ask you is more verbal channeling. So as I'm connected with these energies and finding, finding the energies more for me into my mouth, and if you wish to verbal channel, one of the easiest ways to do it is to be surrounded by people who are asking questions they really need to know the answer to okay, because then they act as a circuit that pulls the information through you into them and grounds it in them. Because if the information is just coming into you for you, it doesn't need to go anywhere, and you don't really need to fully get into that state.
If others are asking the question then innocence you can get out of the way and just let it flow through you like electricity grounding into a circuit. Okay, so practice that and you will get better at it. Okay, so at the moment is more just some baby girls or something slightly energy start however you need to start to know that whatever comes through at that moment is appropriate and it is perfectly fine. Don't worry about looking foolish or crazy or sounding like it doesn't make sense. Just keep practicing like anything and you will get better at it. Awesome. Does that help? It does? Yeah. So anything else? Enjoy your journey to the Amazon, you will find something there that will also amplify your ability to connect to the hybrid children. Beautiful. Thank you so much, Michelle, you are lovely.
Hello, Bashar. Good day. Good day. I had no idea I was going to be coming
Coming here until this morning, oh, I followed the bread crumbs and then realized, Oh, I gotta go see this event. Oh, all right, and who left all those messy bread crumbs on the ground for you to follow?
I am a bit of a slob sometimes. So I guess I did. Oh, all right.
But nevertheless doing so lead you where you need to be? Yes. As always. Yes. Last night I had a vision of Willa. Yes. And a sense of her energy. All right. You could say hi to her in some way. I'd appreciate it just said hi to her. Oh, okay. Great. And I also had a knowing that I was going to be coming up today, a very strong sense. It didn't seem filled with any negative ego. I'm not sure if I've sensed that before. All right, well, now you can practice knowing what that feels like. So that you can allow yourself to know when you know as opposed to when you want
wonder about something that's a different frequency. So now you can get used to that by using that sensation as a marker for when you're in the proper state to know what you need to know.
Great, thank you. Yes. Why didn't do it? You did.
Thanks for reminding me. I understand. Yeah. Um, let's see. You've mentioned before that questions hold the answers. Yes, of course, because if you didn't have the answer somewhere within you, you wouldn't conceive of the question. So it's an issue of taking that bent over little question mark and straightening it out into an exclamation point.
All I have left is Do you mind if I share a bit of about myself with the audience a bit, a bit? Sure. I can help assist with locating, acknowledging and releasing negative beliefs.
I'm also looking for a place to stay in the next
Few days. I'm a
I am and I'm an artist, musician, composer. And I have some experience with improv acting. And I feel like there's something else that's not coming to me right now. That's all right. But that will be sufficient to allow any synchronicity for those that seek what you have to offer to make a connection with you. Thanks so much. Take care. Thank you.
diva until you Good day.
I have
like a three four question. Oh, all right. Let's unpack it.
And the first the first one is
the connection between spirit and mind. Yes, you want to know about that? You know, we address that before you continue to the others.
We can address that one first Yeah, all right.
Spirit is your natural state, a non physical expression of your existence as a consciousness
or what might be called soul. At first, the soul then, in desiring to have what you would call a physical experience, will in a sense, create a division within itself. And in that division, there is the non physical higher mind that remains in spirit to act as a guide for the physical mind that is then created in order to have the physical experience
when the physical mind which is composed of belief systems that reinforce the validity of physical reality as being real, through the idea, the reinforcement through emotions and the idea of thoughts and behaviors and experience
says that reinforce the belief system. That is the structure of the physical mind. And as the physical mind has its physical experience.
It sort of takes the unfired clay of the soul and starts turning it into the ceramic of the spirit that is specifically representative of that particular personalities experience in physical reality, which is then used by the soul to expand. So soul higher mind physical mind, spirit through the experience back to the soul. Does that make sense? Yeah, you're getting there. All right. So
for instance, I can I consider myself always in high spirits. Well, all right. Always in high spirits. Yes, but not always incorrect mine. So I'm trying to all right. Yes. Sync those two. Yes. So the spirits Yes, yes, I unders correct. My I understand. I understand. So the idea
idea of the mind not being aligned with the high spirits, is due to belief systems that construct the physical mind and whether or not those belief systems are out of alignment with who you truly are as a spirit, or in alignment with who you truly are as a spirit. So the idea is to examine what belief systems you might be holding on to maybe even unconsciously, that are out of alignment with who you truly are vibrationally that's the process by which you bring the mind the physical mind into alignment with the spirit. Does that make sense? Yes. So fear based belief systems, negative based belief systems will always push you out of alignment with your true vibrational spirit. Positive belief systems will bring you back into alignment with the vibration of your spirit. It's as simple as that. So finding out what those belief systems are that are making you out of alignment and letting them go will bring you back in
alignment with your high spirits
as a mind,
now the heart receives the vibration communication directly from the higher mind and then bounces that communication into the physical mind. But it has to go through the filter of the belief system. So the heart reminds you in a sense as a physical reminder of who you really are. And this gives you an opportunity to examine what belief systems the physical mind may be holding on to in its construction that isn't allowing it to receive that communication as clearly as it could.
Yes. Does that make sense? Yes. All right. Does that answer your question? The first question, yeah, Yes, I know. Does that answer the first question? Yes. All right, and what is your second and the second questions? Is how
how to listen
and hair
better
As a way to
sustain
a higher synchronicity? Well, again, we have given you all the formula, you act on your passion every moment that you can on whatever contains the highest amount of excitement more than any other option. You do that to the best of your ability, taking it as far as you can, until you can take it no further. And then you look for the next thing that contains more excitement, even just a little bit more and more attractiveness, more curiosity, more passion than any other option, no matter what it is, no matter how simple it is, and you act on that one next, and take it as far as you can until you can take it no further. And you do all these actions with absolutely zero assumption zero insistence on what the outcome is supposed to be. And no matter what manifests no matter how it looks, from the actions you take, you remain in a positive state so that you can extract a beneficial effect
from whatever it is that manifests, because whatever it is that manifests, even if it's something that you neutrally and objectively don't prefer, you have to know it's got to be there for a reason that could serve you. And by remaining in a positive state, as you say, remaining in high spirits, and not giving over to the definition of the negative idea, or the non preferred idea in a negative way, then you will remain in a state that will allow you to receive the benefit from that thing having manifested. And that simply means what you're doing is using what you don't prefer, in a way that you do prefer. And that allows you to sustain that energy because you're making choices that are in alignment with clear definitions of who you are and what you prefer to be. Is that making sense?
Well, I'll add something to that. But does that make sense for the moment? Yes, because you
some time ago, I heard you talked about that, and I
went out and realize that yes, do what excites you. And with the more you do that you get more excited. And you do that with no insistence, no assumption, right, right of what the outcome ought to be. Because the truth is, when you're honest with yourself, you understand the truth is, you have no clue what the best result actually needs to look like. None. The physical mind is not designed to know how something needs to happen. The higher mind knows how something needs to happen. So it's about letting go of the negative ego assumption that the physical mind is supposed to know exactly what things are supposed to turn out to be. It really has no clue. Sometimes you might coincide in the physical mind with something that manifests that is coming from the higher mind as well. But more often than not, you really have no idea what things are supposed to happen that really do serve you best.
So the idea is to let go of any insistence that you do. Now, also, as you say, to maintain that particular state is simply an understanding of how things work. And realizing that what we're giving you as this information is not a philosophy. It's actually literally a description of how reality works. It's an instruction manual. So if you just follow the instructions, it will work to your advantage. That's the way it's designed. The idea also is to ask the questions at every moment where you might question yourself at every moment where you might seem to be out of alignment, you stop and stay in that moment, and ask the question in one of two ways, what would I have to believe is true about myself in order to be experiencing what I'm experiencing in my emotions, my thoughts, my behavior, or the overall experience of my life.
And if you listen, you will get the answer as to what that belief is, or because most of you are so used to dealing with the idea of fear
You can ask the question in another direction. And that is, if I just allowed myself to be who I really prefer to be, what am I afraid might happen? That will usually reveal the negative belief system that then you can work with to let go of and letting go of it is simply an issue of examining it closely enough to understand that it actually makes no sense anymore to hold on to it. And once something makes no sense, it's gone. If you still hold on to that belief, if you still experience the misalignment, that should be your first clue that there is another belief making that one continue to make sense to hold on to. And as soon as you get down to examining the foundational belief, the negative belief that doesn't work for you, and let that one bow all the secondary negative beliefs will collapse along with it. But sometimes, a foundational negative belief will hide under secondary negative beliefs and allow you to think
That you have let the foundational one though, when all you've done is let a secondary one go. Because all beliefs need to perpetuate themselves in order for you to continue to have a physical reality experience because physical reality isn't real, they have to convince you that it's real. And the only way a belief can convince you that it's real is convince you that what it's telling you is a fact. But negative beliefs will only tell you negative things about yourself. You have to let go of buying into the idea of what it's telling you, and sometimes to perpetuate themselves. negative beliefs will hide under other beliefs, or make you so afraid to let go of them that you simply won't do it. You have to see through those things as the way the negative belief is simply designed to perpetuate itself. What they're telling you are not facts. They're just a way of keeping you from letting them go. Is this helping? Yes. Does that answer the second question sufficiently?
Well,
part of the second question was you kind of you sort of answered it.
To the gentleman that came before me. Yes, it's about
there again, it was. You said that when you were experienced? Yeah, that's why your mind was able to bring it up. All right, you have a positive experience the likes a Legos talking about listening and hearing. Yes. So you had that experience. And I was talking about sustaining that. What I'm saying is, the sustaining is automatically built in. It's not an extra thing you have to do. What we're talking about when we give you the formula is a complete kit. It comes with everything you need, including the idea of sustaining because let me put it to you this way. If you're actually acting on your excitement, if you're truly acting on your passion, What other choice would you make that would seem more reasonable?
You wouldn't make another choice to do something else. So
The very idea of simply continuing to choose to act on your excitement, because no other choice seems sensible automatically contains the sustaining
because you're simply not seeing any other choice as making sense. Right? Right. So if no other choice makes sense, you never leave that state, you're automatically sustaining it by no other choice making more sense. It's that simple. Does that answer it? Yes. Thank you. Alright. And the third. That's, that's it, because the answer the gentleman before me, all right. You said something to him that answered the thing. All right. How synchronous others. Thank you. Thank you.
Remember, it just all comes down to making choices This is your greatest power, the freedom to choose. So just decide
That what it is you prefer to choose and keep choosing it. Otherwise, you're saying that something contrary to that makes more sense. Examine the belief that would make you believe that and realize it makes no sense. Just keep choosing what you prefer. Why choose anything else?
And to you good day is really loud.
You kind of shocked me. So I
want to make sure you're all awake. I'm awake now.
So, experiences.
Yes. Okay. So
let's say you regret
an experience out of your past. Oh, not replay that again.
You had
a sexual experience when you were a kid? Yes. That you regret. All right. And because of that,
Because of that, yes. All the way pure. Alright. So let me ask you this question. Are you that kid now? No. So why are you continuing to recreate that experience in your present? I think is.
So why are you choosing to continue to recreate that experience in your present? If you're not that person anymore? Did you learn from it? But did you learn from that experience that you preferred something different? I'm not sure that I'm, I'm not sure that all the way believe that I'm not that kid because
in a moment you get to that in a moment. Answer this question first. Did you learn something from that experience that allowed you to realize that you prefer something different? Yes or no?
Yeah. All right. So are you applying that new knowledge in your life now what you learned, are you behaving in a different
Way, am I behaving in a different way? Yes. All right. So doesn't the new behavior supersede what happened in the past? What a superseding take the place of doesn't didn't replace what happened in the past? Because you have learned from it and are now applying a new behavior? Doesn't that make you a different person?
Once a yes. Why do you want to say yes?
Because Because it feels better, doesn't it? It does feel better than why not believe it? Regardless of what society says.
Why not believe you are a different person now?
Because society makes me feel wrong.
Because society says what? They make me feel wrong, or they make me feel they don't make you feel anything.
thing.
They may suggest how you could make yourself feel. But if you don't prefer to feel that way, why are you agreeing with them? Because you're the one making yourself feel what you're feeling. No one else can make you feel anything. That's right. So I know I just practice. So is there a way to get there? Is it probably by following the highest excitement, the then formula will help help. But you also have to really understand how things work, what the structure of existence is, like. Everything exists here. And now. You understand the time is an illusion. Yes, even your scientists understand this now, yes, it's not real. It's a side effect. Time is a side effect of your consciousness, shifting through billions of parallel reality moments every second. So if everything exists here, and now the only way you can experience what
What appears to be different moments is by actually shifting your focus within the now to a different now, which means you're a different person. Because everything that changes in the now changes everything in the now, it's not the same reality from one moment to the next, literally. Otherwise you wouldn't have the experience of time. So the idea is that you literally are a different person, when you change anything about yourself, and you're becoming a different person billions of times a second. So it's not about the idea of learning how to change it's about the idea of realizing that you're constantly changing and constantly a different person in a different reality and a different version of Earth. Moment to moment to moment to moment to moment to moment to moment, and you get to say what you are, what person you are, how you define yourself every single moment. So you get to choose as I just said, Your greatest power is the freedom to choose who you prefer to be. And it doesn't matter what anyone
else thinks you should be. They're not living your life, they're not your reality, you are your own, you know, reverse. So be who you prefer to be define yourself, as you prefer to behave as you prefer to knowing that it's just as real as anything else you've ever done, because that wasn't actually you.
You have to understand that everything exists at the same time, which means every single moment is actually about a different person. So even though you might have this illusion of continuity, that that younger person was you. It isn't you, it's a different person. You're a different person than that you it's not the same you, it may look like you may be creating a continuity that makes it seem like there's a continuous stream between that younger you and this particular you but there isn't, that's an illusion.
That's different.
Different person, it's not you.
You've changed, and therefore you're a different person literally.
Yes, yes. That's how it works. So be the person, you know, you are now, instead of recreating the idea that you are still a person, you've never been.
You've never been that person. Now that you are defining yourself in this way, that definition literally makes you a completely different person who has never been that other person. This is what we call the 13th step. This is the idea of the true understanding that every change is total change, and that things are changing. As I said billions of times per second.
I'll use the analogy that people on your planet often use of what you call addiction. When you see people suddenly stop doing addicting behavior, some kind of miraculous
For one day they are having that behavior in the next day they are not. It's not because they actually stopped doing it. It's because the person they've become never did it. They have no history of doing it. And that's why it's so easy for them to not have any urges about the idea that they used to do it is because they never did. They're not the same person literally, anymore. Never have been that person.
The illusion of continuity is broken.
That's how you allow yourself to know you're changing, truly changing into different people every moment, let go of the illusion of continuity that anchors you to a past you never had because everything is created from the present, including the past. So my past is even different now. Yes, was okay. That's the idea. Now it's going to seem to be whatever
You create yourself to be is going to come with whatever past you still believe is relevant to you. But as you change the relevant definition, you're going to create a past that makes sense for the person you are now because that's how it works in space time. If you change yourself differently enough, you have to create a past that makes it make sense in space time as to how you became the person you are now, which means you had to have added different facets than you had before. In order to be the person you are now. Because everything is created from the present. There's no such thing as the past. It's an illusion. It's just another parallel present reality that you can decide to experience or not. So break the continuity and realize that every single moment that you become a different person, you have a different past. It may seem like it's always been the past, but that's just what has to come with it in order for you to have a sense of continuity in space time, reality.
Okay, many of you don't even know how many paths you've experienced, even collectively, as we have often given examples. What you consider to be your history as a collective right now may not necessarily have been your history five minutes ago, but it will seem to have always been your history. Oh, yes. Everyone knows that an X bc this. You don't know that. That's the way it was five minutes ago. It might have been completely different five minutes ago, but it's going to seem like it's always been that way when you create a new past. Okay.
Is this helping? Yeah, this is hoping All right. Um, I just want to share my experience of the weekend. Because I think it's helpful and I, there comes a question with it. Yeah. Last Days, just like just being in the room. Yes.
I asked the question the first day and then but just being in the room, I felt like my vibration was shifting, shifting, shifting shifting levels because you are picking up on the free
Quincy that we give off through the channels body, and you're willing to match the frequency that's a higher frequency representation of yourself. And I also think because I allowed it this time, too, because you taught us to see everything as a positive.
And also remember what we have called the triple A formula. On your culture, you have the synchronous convenience of having something called triple A, which you often use to rescue you when your vehicle breaks down. So the idea is we're suggesting a different triple A formula when you feel that your vehicle yourself has broken down and you feel the need to be rescued. Allow yourself to remember this triple A formula. A acknowledge what you have, not what you don't have.
Be a
appreciate what you have
and number three a allow what needs to happen next to happen acknowledge appreciate allow that's all you need to bring yourself back to center acknowledge what you have not what you don't have appreciate what you have and allow what needs to happen next to happen is this part of the excitement Formula Two or it is a subset of it? It's a permission slip designed based on it. Okay, yes. Now in the excitement for me were what really helped me to like increase my vibration is the the I feel like I always followed my excitement. Will Not always, not always but like recently I've been really going for it and all right, not doing the insist not having the insistence. Yes. I feel like we're always when something happened that I didn't
Like so much prefer preferred? Is it truly a recognition of neutral non preference? Or is it a fear reaction, you have to have the ability to discern that honestly, within yourself to
it might have been a fear reaction, but I cleared that out by seeing, giving you the possibility that it's like giving it a positive. I'm giving you the positive meaning. It doesn't mean that you say that what is negative is positive, it means you stay in a positive state so that you can recognize how to use what is negative in a positive way.
How do you stay in a positive state if you see somebody not explain that before?
What other choice Are you giving yourself?
Why would you leave the positive state? What reasons are you creating to leave it
is the natural reaction or it is not a natural reaction, it is a learned reaction. So how to really learn by following the formula and keep practicing it until it becomes not second nature first nature. So by following the formula, it will automatically keep doing it just like anything. If you want to learn to play an instrument, what do you do? You keep practicing. So just keep doing it. Every chance you get remind yourself to go back into that state. Okay. That's it. I have all you have to do. I have a question about the formula. Yes. And I'm making it as an example because I think it's easier this morning for my highest excitement today clearly was coming here. Otherwise you wouldn't be here. Exactly. But I realized there's a there's a pull a difference in excitement. So let's say my highest excitement is here, but there's a time span for me waking
Up to me getting here. So, so why can't that be exciting to that? That can, that can, I'm just asking it because when I wake up in between those little moments, should I still ask every moment can be as exciting as the next It doesn't matter what it is you're doing. Do it in the way that's most exciting for you.
Even the simple things, getting out of bed getting dressed, do it in the way that's most exciting for you so that you are allowing those moments to be what they can be. Don't diminish them, don't devalue them, North Korea, so on the way to my eyes, eyes. No, no, it's not on the way. Every moment is part of your excitement if you will allow it to be an act as if it is and do it in the way that is most exciting. You're making a difference.
Friends between those moments and other moments by saying I'm on the way to my ex, I know every moment because on some points, it doesn't feel like I know what my next time I don't have to know. It's very simple, very simple. You don't have to know the ultimate. Just take it a step at a time. If you want to again, practice this, do it in exactly the way I just suggested. When you wake up, wake up in the most exciting way you can. What do you want around you when you wake up? You want flowers in your bedroom? Do you want a certain scent in your bedroom? You want a certain chime on your alarm? If you use that? Do you want to wake up to music wake up in the most exciting way you can. If you want to stay in bed for a few minutes and recount your dreams. And that's more exciting. Do it when you finally decide that you wish to be excited about rising from your bed dude in the most exciting way you can. Whether it's a soft calm swinging of your legs over this
land
Your feet and those wonderful cozy slippers or jumping and leaping out of bed fully naked into the bedroom.
Do it in the way that's most exciting for you. And then every moment will feel fulfilling. And it's not that you will be ignoring them and invalidating them by saying that they're nothing more than a way on the way to your excitement. This is what we're talking about every moment.
So make every moment a way, use your imagination. Is it good to ask the question every moment or does it make you just if that excites me, but once you practice it and get used to doing your life in a way, you won't have to keep asking the question you will know what to do because you'll know yourself. Remember, it comes down to that ancient phrase Know thyself. So when you know who you are, you will start doing the things in the way that you would do them. That will always be the most
Exciting where you can do it. Because why would you do those things any other way? If you are living your excitement then do everything in your life in the most exciting way you can. Everything. Don't leave anything out. Why miss a moment? Why miss that precious, beautiful, exciting moment, as I described up slipping your toes into those cozy slippers? Oh, that's ecstasy in that moment.
Why miss out on that because you're in such a hurry to get somewhere more exciting.
Don't rush ahead. What's your hurry? You are an infinite eternal being. What's your hurry? enjoy every moment. Okay. All right. Does that help? That helps. All right.
Then I would suggest it for the moment. You find the most enjoyable way to get back to your seat. Thank you. Thank you